pour ça quand j'avais encore un vrai
travail ma boss m'a demandé vers quoi tu
te vois évoluer dans les prochaines
années et je lui répondu à des pressions
et je pense que c'est la seule fois elle
a cru en moi
mais en parlant de pression j'ai essayé
d'utiliser tender un peu wes que sur
tender le stand francophones ont manqué
et c'est c'est compliqué honnêtement
déjà parce que moi quand je vois
quelqu'un qui met dans sa bio tinner je
recherche du fun je lui envoie ma vidéo
de montreux une vue et une vue après on
dit [ __ ] un million de vues
allaitement 210 parce que j'ai souvent
envie de baiser
mais j'ai du mal aussi avec thinard
parce que je ne comprends pas les sous
texte les sous-entendus et où je ne
comprends pas ça moi si un mec me dis à
23 heures on va chez toi on joue à fifa
mais je sors le jeu à une demi heure
plus tard je comprends plus rien ma vie
j'ai une [ __ ] dans la bouche la mekhlouf
qu'équipe
[Applaudissements]